interestingly I don't even know how this
thing happened Senator Ted Cruz from
Texas ends up on The View yesterday and
they're going off on him they're all
ganging up on him including the fake
conservative I think her name's Alyssa
Farah so they've got all you know it's
all lefties and then they have one fake
conservative uh and they're all going
off on him about uh Trump and election
denial and a whole bunch more and Cruz
did not fall for their trap try to say
the election was fair and square and
legitimate you know who y'all don't do
that to you don't do it to Hillary
Clinton who stood up and said Trump
stole the elections
who said that the election was stolen
they sat here and said it was
illegitimate and you guys were fine with
it okay so so it's illegitimate
Republicans
no you know here's the thing we may not
like when Republicans win but we don't
go and we don't storm we don't try to
change but
[Applause]
did I miss an entire year of antifa
riots where cities across this country
your position is the left doesn't engage
in violence really no they wanted to
know our friend Mike Pence you just
accused us of doing something we didn't
do you said Hillary Clinton didn't say
whatever she didn't say I'm saying to
you listen
okay
[Applause]
Hillary Clinton says the election is
stolen from you Hillary Clinton in 2002
George W Bush was selected Not Elected
Joe Biden Al Gore was was elected
president so Joe Biden yeah
all right so I know you guys got it
right we've played these clips a million
times Hillary Clinton not only did she
tweet that Donald Trump was an
illegitimate president she has said it
on video Russia collusion hoax the
impeachment uh Stacy Abrams repeatedly
saying that she was the uh rightly
elected governor of Georgia
etc etc like you guys get it but these
people are never confronted the way that
Ted Cruz did and you can see once they
were confronted Whoopi just doesn't even
honestly does not know what she's saying
she's like well you said whatever you
said about whatever you said and that's
what you said and it's like this is why
it's important to stand our ground and
tell them the truth because they often
have blind spots let's continue here is
Ted Cruz giving it back to noted racist
Sunny Hostin that was standing now let
me ask you the senator the conservative
platform I think was easily identifiable
years ago uh it was limited government
low taxes strengthening National Defense
Family Values I think it's a little
hypocritical for Republicans to be able
to stand behind Family Values right now
having voted in you know the twice
impeached former disgraced president and
backing the president still uh former
president but in 2020 the Republican
Party didn't even put out an agenda
right and I asked this question on the
show all the time what
do the Republicans stand for and what is
the Republican agenda it's very simple
I'll give you three words jobs freedom
and security when it comes to jobs
listen when you cut taxes when you
reduce regulations when small businesses
expand you have lots and lots of jobs
still sure the government has important
roles but but let's be clear
under the Trump Administration with
Republican majorities in both houses we
had the lowest unemployment in 50 years
with the lowest African-American
unemployment deficit ever recorded no
not worth 31 trillion now so I agree the
deficit listen I've stood up to my own
party a bunch of times but when you've
got poverty going down we had the lowest
African-American unemployment ever
recorded lowest Hispanic unemployment
ever recorded that's a big deal this
election in November I think is going to
be a tidal wave I think Republicans are
going to retake both houses and the
biggest reason people at home are saying
okay is my life better today than it was
two years ago and I think for the vast
majority of Americans the answer is no
and I mean Sunny she's just she's not a
good person and she's not very good at
her job to just hand him that and you
think he was ready three words jobs
Freedom security he could have just like
literally poured gasoline on the table
throwing a match down blown the whole
thing up and that's how the view could
have ended right there